hello my name is Leslie and today I'm
looking for a worthwhile companion with
whom to travel to San Diego let's go
Jennifer yes good get on in can you hear
me back there
oh all right good who do you think would
win in a fight between Batman and the
predator Batman
why do you think Batman would beat the
president the Batmobile yeah predator
has gadgets too and he's got the face of
an evil space crab so you think he'll
scare Batman because he looks weird oh
yeah he's a billionaire playboy he's
never seen anything so ugly and weird
get out of my car
you're really Lance you know you're the
second passenger today I've had named
after a medieval weapon who is your
favorite Star Wars bounty hunter wrong
your favorite stars bounty hunter is
boss you are unworthy to ride with me to
San Diego Lance get out now who do you
think would win in a fight between the
Hulk and ant-man feel like the ant-man
would just just run and sneak it you
feel no this is not about emotions this
is about logic get out please give me
five stars like Keira like your outfit
as that tears that load of the Rings
Lord of the Rings no it's Game of
Thrones get out of my vehicle Game of
Thrones Olivia yeah so let me add you
like superhero movies such in question
do you have a boyfriend I do all right
get out can't believe you led me on like
that five stars just as I thought no one
is worthy to join me on my quest to San
Diego
Leslie rides alone
[Music]